i'm pleased to say as you can see the
home secretary pretty patel joining us
once again in the studio good to see you
minister
um let's start with those reports this
morning number 10 source indicating to
us that there may well be progress
in those negotiations with france what's
the current state of play well you heard
yesterday from the prime minister he's
been speaking to president macron
my colleague grant shaps the transport
secretary has also been speaking to his
counterpart
we speak to our colleagues in france
constantly on a range of issues
and that work has been underway over the
last 24 hours
and we'll continue today do we think
that we might get a resolution at some
point well we're working to get a
resolution i think that's really
important to put this into context you
know it's in both
our interests both countries to ensure
that we have flow
and of course there are european haulers
right now who want to be going home
and quite frankly it's in both our
interests to carry on those discussions
and negotiations and we will see what
materializes today
what is then the situation in and around
the port of dover this morning there was
some
debate over the number of lorries that
there were in kent there was a figure
quoted at the press conference yesterday
that
that seemed to underestimate do we know
the number of lorries that are currently
parked up
well i think it's important to recognize
the figures fluctuate so for example
there would have been many hauliers
yesterday you know dropping off their
goods in other parts of the country and
then going back down to dover
of course the number one message has
been to avoid dover the other point to
say is that of course we
we have our contraflow measures in place
right now
that it was operation stack it's now
operation brock where we've now
activated our manston
site that's an inland site that
basically
where hauliers go to to stop them from
queuing to get to the port
that's all part of our regular planning
that we have in place
so those numbers will fluctuate but
quite frankly right now i spoke to the
chief constable of kent yesterday you
know those plans were always in place
and they have been activated
in terms of the reports this morning of
a potential way through
uh in the negotiations between france
and uh france and london
testing of uh people at the ports itself
i mean labour have already suggested we
should be using spare capacity
to test at the ports but but on just the
specific issue of getting
holly hollar's back moving again is that
something that's been considered
we're considering everything um and
rightly so we're in a global
health pandemic and of course the reason
why these measures are in place you know
from a france
from france's perspective in other
countries is because of the spread of
coronavirus
now you know i spend a lot of my time in
ports and i see what it's like when
hawley has come through
they're self-contained they're in their
cabs they're in their vehicles
but i think at you know the end of the
day we have to do everything we can to
stop the spread of this virus
so we're in discussions as i've said
with our french counterparts grant shaps
is having those discussions
and we will find a resolution you know
and these suggestions are
absolutely part of the discussion i
suppose the concern will be on the part
of the french
and indeed everyone else on the
continent it's not just that a
hollywood driver could be traveling back
with the original strain of
kova the original variant of covid19 but
instead this this new variant the one
identified
uh by psychiatric violence yesterday uh
as quite so troublesome
well i think that's right and this new
strain of coronavirus
as we've all been saying you know on the
airwaves for the last few days in fact
over the weekend
which is why we have these new measures
of course that have been brought in with
tier four
this is a stronger strain of the virus
in the sense it's you know it's more
transmittable
um it's a bouncy virus so obviously
people can catch it
in a you know much much more easier way
we have to do everything possible
like you know i've i've sat here before
all my colleagues have as well
emphasizing the need to keep each other
safe we want to squash this virus
we want to do much more to prevent the
spread of the virus which is why we have
so many measures such as social
distancing
testing but obviously you know just
making sure that the public are aware of
the dangers of this virus
i i suppose the question is though are
the government actually doing everything
they can do at the moment so patreon
valence said that this variant is
everywhere we know that there is an
outbreak in cumbria that is of some
concern
but the words that he used the starkest
statement of where we are right now in
our battle against the coronavirus was
given not by the prime minister
yesterday but by sir patrick
measures are going to need to be
increased in places
we're not going to be seeing them
decrease are we looking at everywhere
being in
tier 4 before too long well i think it's
important to say
you know as this virus changes grows
the government takes proactive measures
we've seen that certainly over the last
72 hours over the weekend we have seen
that happen
the fact of the matter is when you look
at various parts of the country
coronavirus is around i remember sitting
here last week
talking about the surge that we've seen
in the virus look at wales look at the
east of england my own county as well
look at london and the rates of
transmission it is inevitable
as people travel and of course we're
urging people not to travel for the sake
of everybody's health
that you know we have to take strong
measures and we're doing that we're
constantly reviewing these measures as
well
is it inevitable though that we will see
other parts of the country move to tier
four that was the very strong suggestion
given by the chief scientifically well
of course if the virus continues to
spread
then we will take stronger measures
because at the end of the day our
objective is to save lives and to keep
people safe
but right now it's not for me to preempt
any change because obviously there'll be
a natural review mechanism
in two weeks time i i suppose the
problem is that there are there are
figures circulating this morning they
were reported in the times they've been
confirmed as as accurate by our own
deputy political editor
that by february the reasonable worst
case scenario is i mean it's it's pretty
alarming
700 thousand cases a week perhaps by
february
twenty thousand hospital admissions five
thousand deaths i mean first do you
recognize those figures
well i think first of all what i would
say we are in this health pandemic
and our response has been incredibly
strong look at the measures that the
government has undertaken
all based on saving lives and protecting
our nhs as well
we are very conscious of the fact this
is we're into into the winter period now
we're seeing hospitals already you know
experience an increase in demand
so it's right that we take protective
and protect um preventative measures
which this government is constantly
doing
so you know we can't just sort of work
on you know what will happen in february
we have to stop
you know numbers from rising now and we
will take all the necessary steps and
measures required to do so
well then one has to ask given the fact
that the evidence emerging from nerve
tag is that perhaps
children are as susceptible to this
variant
as adults you know the reason the only
reason that the schools were able to
open up after the first lockdown was
scientific evidence suggesting
that transmissibility amongst younger
people was lower
that doesn't that no longer appears to
be the case that does rather suggest
we really need to immediately review
whether or not schools can safely reopen
in general
i think first of all neil it's important
to talk about you know issues and
recognize mass testing for example
you know we've seen in parts of london i
saw this last week and i've been
speaking to
you know various people across public
health england local governments in
london
but also the police in london as well
you know surge in that capacity for mass
testing
we want to protect everyone and of
course we want to protect children too
now recognizing this sort of new strain
of coronavirus
how bouncy it is it's moving around much
more if we have to take measures to
increase testing in schools clearly the
government will do all that
these are preventative and protective
measures but quite frankly you can't
look at them in isolation of course
that's part of the wider approach that
the government is undertaking but i
think it is
true but i think it is also fair to say
home secretary that this morning
you would not be in a position to
guarantee that the schools will reopen
on the first day of term well we want to
keep schools open let me be clear about
that
you do but you can't guarantee that we
will take all the appropriate measures
around protecting children
the health of children and also
protecting teachers and the rest of the
population as well around schools
but i do want to emphasize the role that
mass testing plays
that math testing is up and running
across the country as we know
and we have been obviously speaking
about math testing in schools
and that is something that is under
discussion right now across government
for january when the schools
eventually go back given that the
scientists for the time being at least
seem to be in the dark as to as to why
this variant of the viruses has
increased transmissibility
isn't it possible that we might actually
have to go all the way back
to looking at the social distancing
rules themselves
to see whether or not they are effective
the gap you're keeping the distance
between us
we now know we don't actually know if
this distance between you and i
right now is sufficient to guard against
this new variant
well i think it's important to reflect a
on all the measures that the government
has undertaken
and actually these these measures you
know they're not they're not concocted
just in whitehall they're based on
advice from scientific medical advisors
you know if new strains appear and this
virus has been mutating in many many
ways we know this already
then of course all measures are under
review you know social distancing
um obviously tearing etc those reviews
will continue
but i think the most important message
that i have right now
is this continuation of coronavirus we
are in a pandemic
yes we are speaking about this new surge
this new wave this new variant
this variant is also manifesting itself
in other parts of not just the country
but other parts of the world
it's important therefore that we all
take responsibility
we follow the advice we look after each
other effectively this is what
this is what we're trying to do make
sure that we can take care of each other
undertake our own personal
responsibility to make sure that those
protective measures are in place
what then explicitly is the role of the
police in
enforcing tier iv regulations should we
be seeing police checkpoints on
on roads and transporting routes in and
out of tier four areas
should police be knocking on doors at
christmas time
if they receive intelligence that
suggests the rules are being broken in a
domestic context
well i've said before and i will
continue to say that the role of the
police
is very much to please in the public
domain
and this is not about going into
people's houses or even setting up
roadblocks
i maintain and i've seen this throughout
the year you know i was due to go out
with the police this week i won't be
doing that
um on patrol i have seen almost every
week and on a daily basis
the police in action and engage in the
public around coronavirus
the public are really sensible actually
i spoke to the head of the police
federation just yesterday who said
he and his members have not yet received
the guidance from uh from central
government
as to what they are supposed to be
correct but that that
that is what he said so the guidance
went out on sunday night at seven
o'clock
and i know because i was involved in
that we were working obviously
throughout the weekend
with the mpcc in fact to oversee the
guidance that goes out to all police
forces
so you know the police operate on the
guidance but i think it's important to
emphasize
the police have quite a clear playbook
now when it comes to the four e's
speaking to the public engaging
explaining encouraging
enforcement is the last resort but you
know they have the tools such as fixed
penalty fines
um they go after egregious breaches we
spoke about some religious breaches last
week as well
and it's important that the police
continue to do that they'll be as
visible as they have been across our
communities
is there any chance that we will be
hearing from this government
before christmas any changes to the
current tier system
well i think first of all we have a set
timetable in terms of review periods
we also we also changed that for london
but also let me let me just say as well
you know
we keep everything under review you know
you hear from the government every day
you have ministers here with you
certainly every single morning you know
my colleagues no doubt will keep
you and all your viewers updated in
terms of you know the spread of the
virus
but also a reminder of the protective
measures that we can undertake to keep
each other safe
and we will let you go but just one last
question i mean it's it's been pretty
definitively ruled out but it's always
useful to hear from some of the seniors
yourself
there are no plans there is no
temptation to seek
some form of extension to that brexit
transition no there is not
pretty patel good to see you thank you
very much thank you